We all have our reasons for eating nachos
at 3 in the afternoon.
I happen to have my own. And don’t ask -- it’s
personal.
But more generally, we all eat any kind of food to
accomplish two simple things: to obtain the energy
we need to stay alive and to get the raw materials
required for building all of our tissues and stuff.
That’s because, when it comes down to it, both you
and the food you eat contain those two same things:
Both you and food are made of “stuff”
-- by which I mean, matter, made of certain
kinds of atoms -- and both you and food have
energy stored in the bonds between those atoms.
So all living things need to take in stuff and energy,
and convert it into slightly different stuff and energy.
And you can get some of the things you need
pretty easily. Like, in order to get oxygen
for respiration, to unleash the chemical energy
in your food, you just have to inhale.
But you can’t just breathe in the stuff you need
to build DNA, or actin, or a phospholipid bilayer.
So, how does your body really acquire “stuff”?
That’s where the nachos come in.
This cheesy, crunchy dish is made of all different
kinds of biological matter -- like carbohydrates
and fat and protein -- and it contains a certain,
probably shocking, amount of calories, which
is how we measure energy stored in the chemical
bonds in food.
So if I take, like, a 100-calorie bite of
nachos -- which probably with this much cheese
wouldn’t even be a very big bite -- I can
convert the chemical energy stored in those
carbohydrates and proteins and fats to feed
my muscle and heart cells and maybe, like,
walk a mile -- an activity that happens to
use about 100 calories.
But I can’t just swallow the nachos and watch the
lump of them travel straight to my heart or leg muscles.
In order to actually use this food, I have
to convert the biological matter into something
my body can work with on the cellular level,
which as you know, is pretty darn tiny.
And, the work of converting the stuff in food, into the
stuff that’s in my body, is done by my digestive system.
Human digestion occurs in six main steps -- some of
which you are intimately familiar with. Others less so.
But every step of the way, your body is working
to reduce all the different kinds of molecules
in food into their tiniest and most basic
forms.
The first step? Is, uh, probably everybody’s favorite.
When it comes to what your digestive system ultimately
does, just think of it as a sort of disassembly line.
You could have an order of nachos with The
Works -- I’m talking beef and onions and
sour cream and slices of jalapeño -- and
your digestive system will deconstruct it,
both mechanically and chemically, one step
at a time.
It’s gotta do this because your cells work best
with materials that are in their most basic form.
Your digestive system reduces food to that
level in two main ways: by physically smashing
it to smithereens, and by bathing them, as
much as it can, in enzymes.
Enzymes are proteins that living things use
as catalysts, to speed up chemical reactions.
When used in digestion, enzymes break down
the large molecules in your food into the
building blocks that your cells can actually
absorb.
Those large molecules are called biological
molecules -- also known as macromolecules
-- and everything that you eat, I hope, is
at least partially made of them.
And there are four main kinds: you got the lipids, the
carbohydrates, the proteins, and the nucleic acids.
Each possesses its own density of chemical
potential energy, or caloric value, like for
example, 1 gram of carbohydrate contains about 4
calories, while a gram of fat contains about 9 calories.
But many of these biological molecules are
polymers -- or sequences of smaller molecules
-- and your cells aren’t really equipped
to take them up whole.
What your body trafficks in are those polymers’
individual components -- called monomers -- and
there are four main kinds of those, too: fatty
acids, sugars, amino acids, and nucleotides.
The simple idea behind the whole digestive system
is to break down the polymers of macromolecules
in your food, into the smaller monomers that
your cells can use to build their own polymers,
while also getting the energy they need.
And, what your body needs to build at any
given moment is always changing.
Maybe you need new fat stores so you can have
energy to run a marathon, or new actin and
myosin to build bigger muscles, or more DNA
so you can replace the skin cells you scraped
off your knee when you fell, or more enzymes so you
can digest more food to get more building materials.
To meet your body’s constant, and constantly shifting
demands, your digestive system requires a lot of organs
that perform a lot of specific tasks to break down
and absorb the right nutrient at the right time.
Now, I’m quite sure that you’re familiar
with the key players here -- they’re the
hollow organs that form the continuous tube
that is your alimentary canal, aka the gastrointestinal
tract, which runs from your mouth to your
anus.
It’s worth pointing out that these organs are
hollow, because you are basically hollow, too.
Your digestive tract is really just one unbroken,
insulated tunnel of outside that just happens
to run through your body, and is open at both
ends. You’re a donut.
So the layer of stratified squamous and columnar
epithelial cells that line your tract is actually
a barrier between the outside world and your
inside world -- but it’s a barrier that
allows for the selective movement of materials
between them.
It’s these hollow organs that do the actual
moving, digesting, and absorbing of food,
and they include your mouth, pharynx, esophagus,
stomach, and small and large intestines.
In your mouth, in your esophagus, and at the
other end of things, at your anus, you have
stratified squamous epithelial tissue, just
like your epidermis, to help resist the abrasive
action of like, chewing, like corn chips, maybe.
From your stomach on down, though, the inner
GI tract is lined with simple columnar epithelial
cells, which secrete all sorts of stuff, and
which absorb and process various nutrients.
Most of those columnar cells secrete mucus,
which lubricates everything, and protects
your cells from being digested by your own
digestive enzymes.
So, the innermost epithelial layer of the
tube is known as the mucosal layer, and it
contains some connective tissue as well, which
supplies it with blood.
Surrounding the mucosal layer is the submucosal
layer, made of loose areolar connective tissue,
which helps provide the elasticity that the
tube needs when you eat a whole pizza in one
sitting, and it contains more blood vessels.
And outside that, you have the muscularis
externa layer, which as you might guess, is
where you find the muscles responsible for
moving food through your tube.
Beyond these layers, the GI tract gets tons
of support from the accessory digestive organs,
like your teeth, and your tongue, your gallbladder,
salivary glands, liver, and pancreas.
They’re kind of like a pit crew, and they
mostly help by secreting various enzymes that
help take apart food as it comes down the
tube.
Together, these two groups on the digestive
disassembly line work in six steps to destroy
your food and release and recycle its nutrients.
First, of course, you’ve got to introduce
the food to your digestive system. What you
know as eating, or ingestion, is basically
just creating a bulk flow of nutrients from
the outside world into your tissues.
This is where the work of disassembly begins:
In your face-hole, which scientists call your mouth.
Now, we’re going to get to the details of
what happens here another time, but remember
that food disassembly is both mechanical and
chemical: So your teeth pulverize the bite
of nacho or whatever, while your salivary glands
begin that food’s hours-long enzyme bath.
But the food, at this point, is not nearly
“micro” enough to be of any use to your
cells, so you have to move that mush further
down your tube.
This stage is called propulsion, and its initial
mechanism is swallowing -- which, as you know,
is a voluntary action -- but then it’s quickly turned
over to the involuntary process of peristalsis.
In peristalsis, the smooth muscles of the
walls of your digestive organs take turns
contracting and relaxing to squeeze food through
the lumen, or cavity, of your alimentary tract.
Waves of peristalsis continue through the
esophagus, stomach, and intestines, and they’re
so strong that even if you were hanging upside
down while eating your lunch and drinking
your tea, the food would still soldier on, fighting
gravity, and eventually make it to its final destination.
Don’t do that, though. There’s other reasons
why you shouldn’t be upside down.
Anyway, all of this shipping and handling
mechanically breaks down the food even more,
and even after it goes through the stomach
and its gastric acid, the mechanical work
still continues once it reaches your small
intestine, as more smooth muscle segments
push the food back and forth to keep crumbling
it up.
The goal of all this pulverization is to increase the
surface area of that bite of food by breaking it down
into increasingly tiny pieces, to prepare it to encounter
more enzymes in step four: chemical digestion.
Really, the actual process of digestion only
occurs when the main action becomes
more chemical than mechanical.
And here, the accessory digestive organs -- namely,
the liver, pancreas and gallbladder -- secrete
enzymes into the alimentary canal, where they
ambush the mush and break it down into its
most basic chemical building blocks.
Like I said before, our cells prefer to do
business in the really basic currency of monomers,
like amino acids, fatty acids, and simple sugars.
And digestion allows for the absorption of
those nutrients as they pass from the small intestine
into the blood, by both active and passive transport.
Once those nutrients are absorbed by your
cells, you can finally use the energy inside
of them or use them to build new tissues.
The absorption of the nutrients is the
goal of the entire process.
But, of course, it is not the end of it.
Once your body has sucked out all the nutrients
it wants, indigestible substances like fiber
are escorted out of your body.
Yeah, I’m talking about pooping, or defecation.
And that is the end of the digestive line
-- unless you are a capybara, or one of the
other animals who make sure that they get
the most out of their lunch, by giving the
whole process another round and practicing
coprophagia, aka eating their own poop.
Now, you should notice here that some of the
processes of digestion occur in just one place,
and are the job of a single organ -- like
hopefully you’re only ingesting through
your mouth and eliminating from the large
intestine.
But most of these six steps require cooperation
among multiple organs.
For example, both mechanical and chemical
digestion start in the mouth, and continue
through the stomach and small intestines.
And some chemical breakdown continues in the
large intestine, thanks to our little bacterial
farm there.
Over the next couple of weeks we’re going
to take you and your nachos on a stroll through
your digestive system and see who’s doing
what, where, how, and why.
But for now, I’ve got some nachos to finish,
so I gotta go.
And eating those nachos, as you learned today,
will provide me with energy and raw materials,
by first ingesting something nutritious, propelling
it through my alimentary canal where it will
be mechanically broken down, and chemically
digested by enzymes until my cells can absorb
their monomers and use them to make whatever
they need. And eventually, there will be pooping.
Thanks to all of our Patreon patrons who help
make Crash Course possible through their monthly
contributions. And if you like Crash Course
and want to help us keep making videos like
this one, you can go to patreon.com/crashcourse.
Also, a big thank you to Peter Rapp, Sigmund
Leirvåg, Mikael Modin, and Jeremy Bradley
for co-sponsoring this episode of Crash Course
Anatomy and Physiology.
This episode was filmed in the Doctor Cheryl
C. Kinney Crash Course Studio, it was written
by Kathleen Yale, edited by Blake de Pastino,
and our consultant is Dr. Brandon Jackson.
It was directed by Nicholas Jenkins, edited
by Nicole Sweeney; our sound designer is Michael
Aranda, and the Graphics team is Thought Cafe.